[rhythmic bass beat,
sensual moans]
♪ ♪
- LATRELL?
- WHAT'S UP, BABY GIRL?
- CAN YOU PLEASE TURN
THAT OFF?
- WHY, YOU DON'T LIKE MY MUSIC?
- IS IT MUSIC?
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE A BUNCH
OF SEX NOISES
OVER A BASS LINE.
- OH.
I GET IT.
YOU DON'T LIKE MY MUSIC
'CAUSE I'M GAY.
YOU CAN'T HANDLE
A GAY MAN'S MUSIC.
- NO, NO, NO.
IT'S--I'M TRYING TO WORK HERE,
AND THAT MUSIC
IS WEIRDLY SEXUAL.
- OH, I SEE.
SO MY SEXUALITY IS WEIRD.
YOU JUST CAN'T FATHOM A MAN
BEING ATTRACTED
TO ANOTHER MAN.
- I CAN FATHOM IT.
IT'S--
CAN YOU JUST PLEASE LISTEN
TO SOME OTHER GAY MUSIC,
LIKE BARBRA STREISAND
OR SOMETHING--
- OH, I SEE, I SEE.
OKAY.
SO LISTENING
TO BARBRA STREISAND IS GAY.
STEREOTYPE MUCH?
[keys clacking]
SO YOU SEEING
ANYBODY LATELY?
- YEAH, I-I MEAN, KIND OF.
I THINK--
- 'CAUSE I GOT IT GOOD
LAST NIGHT.
OH, IT WAS LIKE, DAMN!
I MEAN, MY MAN WAS LIKE, BLOP!
LIKE, HE HAD A BABY ARM HOLDING
ON TO A APPLE.
- AW, DON'T CALL IT
A BABY ARM.
- AW.
I SEE.
SO YOU CAN'T HANDLE HEARING
ABOUT HOW I'M GAY.
I'M SORRY.
- YOU JUST REFERRED
TO YOUR BOYFRIEND'S PENIS
AS A BABY'S ARM
HOLDING AN APPLE.
- WELL, THAT'S WHAT
IT LOOKED LIKE.
AND IT'S NOT MY BOYFRIEND,
BY THE WAY.
AND "ANYWHATS,"
YOU'RE HOMOPHOBIC.
- NO, NO, NO.
THAT'S NOT HOMOPHOBIC, OKAY?
YOU'RE EXPLICITLY TALKING
ABOUT SEXUAL THINGS
IN THE WORKPLACE.
- FINE.
THERE'S PLENTY OF STUFF
THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW, UH, MY PENIS CUP,
MY SCROTUM COZIES THAT I HAVE
BEEN KNITTING RECENTLY--
OH, WITH THESE KNITTING NEEDLES
THAT I HAVE JUST NOTICED
LOOK LIKE LITTLE, SKINNY,
PURPLE PENISES,
ET CETERA AND ET CETERA.
- OH, MY GOD.
- CAN I SHOW YOU A PICTURE,
AND THEN YOU TELL ME
IF IT'S GOOD FOR FACEBOOK?
- OKAY, I'M FAIRLY CERTAIN
YOU'RE GOING TO SHOW ME
SOMETHING OVERTLY SEXUAL.
- DON'T YOU PREJUDGE ME!
HERE IT IS.
- AGH! [bleep]!
THAT'S A CLOSE-UP
OF AN ANUS.
- OH, NO, THAT'S NOT AN ANUS.
THAT'S MY ANUS, BABY GIRL.
- THAT'S DISGUSTING.
- OH, I SEE.
SO YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE
A CLOSE-UP PICTURE OF MY ANUS
'CAUSE YOU HATE GUY MEN.
- NO.
I DON'T WANT TO LOOK
AT A CLOSE-UP PICTURE
OF ANYONE'S ANUS.
- HOMOPHOBE.
HOMOPHOBE.
THERE'S A HOMOPHOBE RIGHT HERE.
HO--
[blows whistle]
HOMOPHOBE ALERT!
[high-pitched voice]
HOMOPHOBE!
[imitating siren wailing]
- HEY.
- HEY, BABY.
HOW'S IT GOING?
- GOOD.
READY TO GO TO LUNCH?
- YEAH.
UH, LATRELL, THIS IS GAVIN.
GAVIN, THIS IS LATRELL.
THIS IS MY BOYFRIEND.
- HOW YOU DOING?
- I'M--I'M--
I'M DOING VERY WELL.
HOW--HOW ARE YOU DOING,
GAVIN--GAVIN?
- GREAT. WANT TO GO?
- YEAH.
- NICE TO MEET YOU.
- NO, TRUST ME.
IT'S NOT.
- NO?
- THAT'S THE GUY.
- OH.
- OH...
I GET IT.
I'M NOT PERSECUTED.
I'M JUST A ASSHOLE.
AH.